even though many people think of
three aviva's over under back
over under around everyone think about
that
what actually starts it is the
chasing hand chasing underneath the
other hand
you swing under and that little two beat
that my hand just did is what initiates
the freebie but it's going
under back that was the intro then it
does a freebie and you're locked into 3b
you do it automatically with yourself
but when you're working with a partner
you need to be aware of that talk about
who is going to be the initiator or else
he'll just keep getting all tangled up
and confused
by the way in reverse everything's
flipped upside down so it would actually
be
over the top then we tried it with a
partner we actually kind of broke it
down even to a 2b
so we could just learn that intro we had
to communicate about
who is going to initiate so i'll be the
initiator i'm going to swing
under and back do that a couple times
hang out you can even count count it up
one two
three switch
once you get comfortable with that you
can continue with continuous tv
here we go
this is of course one half a three beat
which we ultimately want to do with each
other
all right here we go
here's another way to learn it i'm going
to initiate and cross underneath them
and then we're just going to stay
with our arms crossed there we go so
just stand here now we can do the arm
stacking okay
i'm underneath and i want to get on top
so we just hang out for a second then he
goes
and i hang out then i go and once you
get comfortable just
doing the switch every once in a while
you can take the extra breather beats
out
and then we're going to preview
basically
left hand like siamese
we got into stances we're facing each
other
but we're not connected here we could do
a move where we're back to front
or we can do back to back
or we can do front back front back
do all those possibilities furthermore
we don't have to stand right
lined up with each other we can offset
each offset
this cross-stance position i'm looking
at he's looking that way
and our arms can interact in a new way
when we're standing like this
if you wanna like if you wanna use a
yoga mat or
just pick a wall that you're gonna look
at in your room that can help you get
oriented
so i'm gonna spin drawing a circle on
the wall in front of me it's kind of
behind
dan and he's drawing in front of him
which is kind of behind me
and we want to make sure our poi if
they're they were wheels are rolling the
same direction so both of our koi wheels
are rolling
that way and now
dan has the easiest way to initiate by
just hopping over my hand and
drawing it through it's like dan's
saying hey john's arm come over here
and i say no i'm gonna go back here you
you come over here
my wall's better
i got right
and you get a little of that and then
you're doing a four feet crosstalk suite
important keys with the four beat cross
stance weave we want to be
far enough apart this way offset from
each other and instead of being like
heel to heel we want to have stepped
back just a little bit
so that there's room in between our legs
so we don't hit each other
and you want to focus on making your
cross points hit
the ground or the ceiling like you're
hitting a golf ball and bringing it back
this is what i mean by that so go ahead
and start out golf ball
i cross and hit the golf ball i cross
and ring the bell
and our arms twist around each other at
about shoulder height
a version of the 3b where we're back to
front
and the person in the front is a
slightly more complicated job
so go ahead and initiate
dan basically does the exact same thing
the person in the back the person in the
front
has to their elbows pointing the wrong
way they have to flip behind them behind
them
back around in front behind behind
background in front
once you get the hang of it it's
basically the same as the 3b weave and
from here you can start
folding between stances as though you
were handcuffed by your wii
and the whole when you change stances
you need to step
when the poi aren't there like indiana
jones dodging
suddenly the doom so when our koi go
behind
dan i can step out the front here
so here comes my car
and that one's pretty easy we're going
from a three beat to a four beat
so we have all this extra time
for one beats really time so step back
is kind of fast
if you drop
and he immediately comes out in front of
me to really break this
transition down i go up and over
dan's arm to the other wall and when i
do i just
leave my coil on that wall for an extra
heat as i step in front of it
so here it comes i cross over leave my
poi there
and he comes in front and only then when
he's come in front of me
do i start to weave if you if you go any
earlier you'll get ahead of yourself you
get tangled up or you'll just
come apart what did we do
that was the meat of it is there any any
other points
yeah okay that was a whole bunch
you